for the first time in the US some
schools could start using facial
recognition for security it's one of the
many areas of society relying on the
technology and that's raising new
privacy and civil rights concerns Carter
Evans met with industry experts to see
how this type of technology works and
why there's pushback all it has to see
is part of my face correct just your
profile many of us still see facial
recognition technology is part of the
future for Sean Moore the future is now
it identify me the second I walked in
the room it did yes we visited his LA
based company true face where he showed
us their capabilities with a photo of me
found online what exactly is the camera
looking at right now it's looking at
those facial features and basically the
mathematical representation of your face
an algorithm is trained to recognize the
person in the photo and look for someone
who could be a match what are some of
the things you see this being used for
it's things like mobile banking access
control is another very very big market
for us where you're entering a building
using your face and the company is now
moving beyond the face developing
algorithms to detect body movement you
look at the the dimensions on your eyes
if you look distracted down to the left
this is where the concern comes in with
your office you don't want them
necessarily using this to know where
you're looking every second this was not
you know not intended for use in an
office to monitor employees and where
they're looking around yeah but someone
might see this and go mmm fortunately
for us we get to choose our clients so
we work very intimately with them and
understand their use case and make sure
that it falls within our our obligation
to society in China the government is
putting facial recognition to use with
plans to install 400 million cameras in
the next three years tracking everyone
from jaywalkers to ethnic minorities
they see as a separatist threat in the
US it's largely unregulated but some
computer science experts are concerned
how companies might use the technology
is this person packing the boxes too
slowly compared to her or his coworkers
person wandered off to take a break for
a little bit too long here's a camera
and it's doing it constantly and turning
up the pressure turning up the heat with
no discretion at Richie trucking in
Fresno drivers are tracked by
face-reading cameras there's two
infrared beams are sitting here so it's
looking for the drivers eyes yep it's
wanting to measure you up if a driver is
distracted or begins to close their eyes
an alarm sounds in this seat vibrates
really as soon as your eyes start to
close as soon as it see the text of that
it's enough of a close it really gets
going the system also sends a video clip
of the incident back to headquarters the
company argues the technology could save
lives this former employee was let go
because cameras captured him using his
cell phone while driving which is
illegal in the state of California we
don't fire them on the spot you know we
try to figure out you know why do you
think this happened so human involvement
is key correct because it's not just the
black and white deal maybe they were up
all night with a sick kid but the camera
doesn't distinguish between that and
whether they were out all night drinking
the night before correct it does not
facial recognition technology may be
developing faster than the federal
government can regulate it so cities
like Oakland California in Somerville
Massachusetts are considering local
bands last month concerns raised by
civil liberties groups in San Francisco
led to a ban of facial recognition
technology for government use what
concerns you about this technology I
think most importantly is the
misunderstanding of how it's used from
accessing your phone accessing your home
your business you know being able to pay
with your face it's not all surveillance
it's not all monitoring but I do think
that if there are not checks and
balances in place there's you know
propensity to misuse this technology and
it's something that we do not want to
see happen for CBS this morning Carter
Evans Los Angeles that's always the case
right idea that your technology is
advancing you have to figure out how to
monitor and regulate it so it doesn't
take oval they they clearly I think have
some kinks but I can also see the good
in it that thing when you're driving if
you're I like it in fact like if your
arse don't know if I like it in the
office
we know who we are in the auto so thank
you Tony